[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between subway and japan and
the u.s this is food wars
[Music]
in japan our sandwiches come in three
sizes this one
is regular
and here we've got
fulong sub
and
this one right here is
party tray this is party tray a which is
three regular sandwiches cut into 12
pieces or we can also get a purty tray
that's three full long subs in the u.s
you have three sizes six inch foot long
and the party tray this is five foot
longs cut into three sections giving us
15 sandwiches not enough partying that
partner platter subway's got you covered
here in the u.s you can also get a three
foot party sub
whoa
yes
yes
time to give this sandwich an exam dude
are you kidding me look at this i'm
seeing ham i'm seeing turkey i'm seeing
cheese
and also we have a giant sub
let me show you
oh
i got this
and this is what it looks like
this is too big
[Music]
in japan our fountain drinks come in
three sizes
this one is small
and
medium
large
here in the u.s subway the website says
it's a small but i talked to the subway
manager and they assured me they don't
have a small so apparently art fountain
drinks are just two sizes medium
which makes no sense because there's no
small
and large
[Music]
at subway i had to fill up myself the
fountain drinks which of course i don't
mind so any inaccuracies rest on my
shoulders and my shoulders alone
40 what not even close and that was like
i filled this up to the brim i'm looking
through this i'm seeing 33 maybe we'll
be generous looking 34. they still
missed it by six
six fluid ounces you guys are skimping
on us
you get a good shot of that is that real
is that really six missing ounces do we
think that six ounces of fluid we're
using there
you better believe i'm on a high horse
right now this is infuriating i'm really
hungry that has a lot to do with it too
on the surface both country sandwiches
look the same but we wanted to get a
closer look here we have a foot long on
white turkey with lettuce tomato black
olives and onions all right i've got the
same one so i'm gonna weigh this
wow so pretty close
scientific accuracy is really important
in the food wars so
now let's open it up and see what's
inside
huh only a 10 gram difference but ours
had a lot more turkey and a lot less
vegetables
[Music]
so here are all the subway menu items
you can get in japan but not in the us
and here is everything you get a u.s
subway you cannot get in japan
so let's start with new exclusive
sandwiches so here we've got tandoori
chicken sandwich
the chicken itself is tender
nine out of ten congrats
so next one we've got tokumori tandoori
chicken sandwich
tokumori means extra large so extra
large tandoori chicken sandwich we've
got spicy egg shrimp
so next one we've got chocolates chicken
and cheese sandwich
this is not good
it doesn't have any taste
man what the fudge so first thing i have
this huge pile of sandwiches here i'll
just try and do some hits here is of
course steak and cheese
buffalo chicken
yeah i don't know maybe it's because
they put all the veggies on here too
they kind of just did
the standard ones that i don't think
this looks very good oh the cali turkey
looks like a spinach on here oh and
bacon yeah okay
not bad they're ruined with the
cucumbers the cold cut combo
this is like the sandwich right if we
were playing family feud and the
category was subway sandwiches i feel
like the cold cut combo would be number
one right oh the baja steak everybody
straight from baja california
you know their blast
now try their steak
everyone in the room just groaned
[Laughter]
i have to know how far is the bathroom
in here
they really loaded with the vegetables
again
why would you want all these gross
veggies on i want the meatball and i
want the sauce and the cheese i don't
want cucumbers
maple sandwich is ruined i'm sneaking a
meatball
yeah the italian bmt
come on this is like the most popular
one so you get the meat there nice
looking meat right glad nice looking
meat thing lift up the meat boo
boo
who ruined the sandwich of vegetables
it is the spicy italian
looks like the bmt but yeah dude in
subway's defense these sandwiches were
made what three hours ago at this point
so here are japan's exclusive regular
menu items so let's start with this
pizza bacon italiana
itadakimasu
i would rate this
seven out of ten
so next one we've got prosciutto
mascarpone
stream avocado
and i love
avocado
next we've got
turkey bacon egg
turkey
as you can see bacon right here
an egg paste
vimeo
it's not that great and next we've got
chili chicken sandwich
this
is
terrible
sabu hey
how dare you
okay
i'm getting full but let's keep going
here we've got
avocado vegetables
[Music]
next we've got
egg sandwich
all right one thing i have to mention is
that most of these sandwiches can be a
solid so if you like salad go ahead but
jill
wouldn't get this for sure you know what
if somebody get a panini press or
something like look at these this took
these sandwiches and like grilled them
or whatever okay this one right here is
the bmt
so i'm just guessing for the melts
they do it on the white bread and they
add a bunch of cheese and they just
grill it right i mean i can't even open
it's like it's locked buffalo chicken
melt maybe there's less vegetables in it
so maybe i do want this and i don't
realize it steak and cheese a philly
cheese stick right yeah i know this one
i know this one
tuna melts
turkey milk yeah i guess i mean i gotta
say like i i haven't tasted them but the
effort in these are just like what are
you guys doing i mean they just like
flatten them
ham melts
what's sp again
it should be s-i but it's sp for spicy
right that's why i'm like wait a second
is this the spaghetti one we've been
talking about
meatball melts what do they do they
flatten the meatballs in there right
it's better less vegetables right this
is the chicken bacon melt
so this is the japan only sandwich
everything on here you can't get in the
us it's a six inch on sesame bread with
tandem chicken mascarpone cream cheese
egg salad shrimp chili sauce and wasabi
soy sauce
this is a mystery sandwich itadakimasu
i said wasabi soy sauce right i got
wasabi attack
it's hard to me
it's got too many flavors and it makes
me confused
this here is the usa only sandwich a
sandwich comprised of only ingredients
you get in the united states and not in
japan so let's start with the jalapeno
cheese bread as meatballs american
cheese pepper jack cheese provolone
cheese banana peppers god spinach ranch
sriracha and pepperoni
here we go
oh it's actually pretty good
i really like this dude oh cool it's not
too spicy the jalapeno breads really
good the meatballs and the pepperoni
work really well together like i said
the banana peppers are actually welcome
in this it kind of makes a little
sweeter then they're gonna bite ah
subway put this on your menu
this is really good i challenge you all
the viewers in the united states start
ordering this sandwich let's put the
pressure on subway to make this make
this like a featured sandwich this is
good so here we've got snack sandwiches
but this one right here is
uncle sandwich an anko is a staple of
traditional japanese sweets the taste
can be enjoyed alone or as a compliment
to other japanese flavors such as matcha
and here we've got
anko and mascarpone
i have an announcement to make subway
has breakfast i'm just a surprise as all
you specifically they have four
breakfast sandwiches here in the u.s a
bacon egg and cheese a black forest ham
egg and cheese
egg and cheese and steak egg and cheese
i don't know which one is which i think
this is the steak egg and cheese
oh it's flatbread too so i can kind of
this looks like a cartoon look at this
look at the eggs
are you kidding me with this
in a subway in the u.s you can get just
about any one of their sandwiches as a
protein bowl from what i can tell that's
their way of calling this a salad so you
know my feelings on salad
i hate them just an example though we
got what looks to be a turkey one
everything that comes in a sandwich
which instead of bread there's a bowl
then once you're done you can throw it
in the ocean
kill a sea turtle who cares right
it's a waste it's an absolute waste just
eat a sandwich like a normal person if
there's nothing wrong with bread just
eat it it's a sandwich yeah and it's
like the shredded lettuce too it's not
like you know like leafy lettuce or
spinach it's that shredded they put in
the sandwich
so here is japan's exclusive size this
one right here is coroporo potatoes
original flavor and next one we've got
coco cora potatoes triple cheese flavor
kodokoto potatoes herb salt flavor the
korokoro means it's like rolling over
and over like
rolling over and over and last one we've
got
corn cream chowder
yeah chips
chips
chips get yourself the baked leis
i mean
the undisputed chip champion in the
united states right here baby nacho
cheese doritos
a favorite a classic glaze we just want
to see what potato chips are like in the
50s get yourself a bag of classic lace
from this vickies jalapeno and lime
cracked pepper i don't think i've had
the lime cracked pepper
these are so good
sun chips i hate sun chips
here's a side that you can get in the
u.s you can't get in japan
i'm going to go muscle man's applesauce
so here is japan's exclusive drinks
this one right here is ascii
and pepsi melon soda oolong tea which is
chinese tea iced coffee soy cocoa
and this one right here is vegetable and
fruit juice which has 11 kinds of
vegetables and three kinds of fruits and
this one right here is pepsi zero and
this one is mocha that's coffee olay and
this one right here is ginger ale and
soy latte soy mango mango orange mango
juice mocha and milk tea cocoa hot black
tea
and herb tea
in the u.s as you notice we have coke
and coke products at our subways so we
have coke and they also have to go
bottles so i went ahead and got diet
coke sprite
and gatorade the fruit punch all right
sauce talk sauce talk
i couldn't get any of them on the side
but we have exclusive sauces here at the
subway in the u.s we can get a red wine
vinegar a yellow mustard a creamy
sriracha a buffalo sauce of course we
also have ranch chipotle southwest
marinara sauce sweet onion sauce and mvp
parmesan
the most valuable parmesan apparently
i was surprised to learn that the
japanese subway doesn't have cookies the
cookies are actually pretty good in the
u.s you can get a chocolate chip cookie
an oatmeal raisin cookie a raspberry
cheesecake cookie and a white chip
macadamia nut cooking all right so let's
move on to japan's exclusive sweets so
let's start with this one chocolate
brownie
we've got
cheese tart
and this one right here is cream soda
float
and this one right here is cream latte
float
and coffee food
[Music]
in japan a six inch turkey serve on
white bread is 261 calories and in the
u.s that same turkey sub is 270 calories
so pretty close but i did notice ours
has much less sodium like 26 percent
less
our six-inch tuna sub is 361 calories
in our tuna it's 430 so a little more
but much more fat i have not eaten
turkey a tuna anything on purpose ever
it smells like cat food don't you think
it smells i guess most cat food is tuna
so yeah this looks super gross but i
have to try it right
let's see if like my distaste is
misplaced
no
i hate that man
do you like calories in japan our most
calorie fake sandwich is the pizza bacon
italiana
1 6 inch is
436 calories in the u.s our most
calorific sandwich is the chicken and
bacon ranch just six inches of this bad
boy is 500 calories so footlong is a
thousand calories
in japan our regular sandwich with a
small drink and small serving of
potatoes the total calories for this
meal is
498 calories in the us a six inch turkey
sandwich with a small drink which the
subway i went to said they do not have
and a bag of chips i went with the
classic lace is 750 calories
in japan this meal total is 790 yen or
7.23 cents u.s in the us that same meal
is 9.14 or about
998.26 japanese yen roughly twenty six
point four percent increase
in japan we focus on having a healthy
diet or chol cats meals chokatsu means
having a healthy diet that contains a
lot of dietary fiber in order to keep
your intestinal environment healthy and
it's getting common in japan to have to
cut meals at home or even at restaurants
because a lot of japanese people have a
constipation problem due to a lot of
stress and lack of exercise
so subway offers a special meal called
choukat's chicken and cheese sandwich
which contains a lot of dietary fiber so
it's going to help you return to regular
bowel movements and you can start your
day with a number two
so we don't have anything like that but
i can only speak for myself that if
you're experiencing
constipation in the united states
may i recommend the steak and cheese at
subway
the subway in japan does not disclose
all the raw ingredients but they did
provide the main raw ingredients for
their breads japan subway flatbread
contains wheat flour yeast vegetable fat
and oils
skim milk powder
wheat protein
salt sugar
barley malt powder
etc well our subway in the us does give
us the ingredients and our flatbread
contains all of events now there's a few
similar ingredients and there's a bunch
that are pretty close that etc in the
japan flatbread that gives me pause i
mean if that's supposed to represent all
of this other stuff that is a huge dot
dot dot or to be continued or yadda
yadda yadda that japan is throwing at
their uh their customers i mean if the
america
has proven anything it's like you can
tell us what's in the food we don't care
we'll still eat it so i don't know
what's up with the etc guys subways tuna
was a bit controversial here in the u.s
starting in january where a class-action
lawsuit made false claims about their
tuna meet the drama continued when a new
york times article claiming to have had
a lab analyzed 60 inches worth of subway
tuna shared the results saying they
could not identify a species of fish and
no amplifiable tuna dna was present in
the sample subway responded of course
saying it uses 100
wild caught tuna and even launched a
website subway tunafacts.com
to give everyone a clear and transparent
look into their tuna process
furthermore usa today did their own
fact-checking and had its doubts about
how the times tested the tuna samples
and pointed out the lab tested for five
tuna species out of 15 and concluded the
tuna was too processed or that there was
no tuna dna different tests have
detected tuna in subway sandwiches and
experts say canned tuna can become
denatured when cooked then i did my own
scientific research to find out what
denature means and the scientists at
dictionary.com said dear joe thanks for
reaching out to dictionary.com the word
denature means to destroy the
characteristic properties of a protein
or biological micromolecule by heat
acidity or other effects that disrupt
its molecular confirmation they went on
to say for further definition inquiries
please just use the search function on
the home page as that is what's there
for don't email us so
believe we want another subway
ingredient controversy that's a bit more
clean cut at least for the good people
ireland is that an irish court ruled
subway cannot call their bread bread due
to its high sugar content in ireland for
bread to be considered bread the amount
of sugar in the dough must be two
percent the flour's weight subway's
bread however the sugar content is 9.2
percent if you're new to food wars hello
we actually have a whole another series
where we compare the us and the uk you
can watch every one of those episodes
right now click the floating box near my
head